- Hi, guys.
Welcome to my channel.
I'm Dr. Sandra Lee,
also known as Dr. Pimple Popper.
I'm gonna post
blackhead extractions...
Look at that.
That's pretty cool.
Cysts being popped...
Not hurting you too much?
I know I'm starting to push--
push around.
I'm sorry.
I made you yell.
I know. That's why.
It squirts on you.
Lipomas being removed
from the skin...
[speaking indistinctly]
'Cause I know
you guys love them,
and I love that you love them.
Enjoy.
- Like I tell my eldest son,
the more it hurts,
the more it squirts.
That's Sandra Lee, M.D.,
better known on the Internet
as Dr. Pimple Popper.
Her videos have
over 1/2 billion views,
proving to women everywhere
that showing off
your ass and titties
isn't the only way
to become Instagram famous.
All you have to do
is go to med school,
then violate doctor-
filthy-patient confidentiality
by posting videos of you
squeezing gallons of hummus
out of their disgusting bodies.
And it doesn't hurt
to be an attractive Asian.
Acne is just nature's way
of keeping teenagers ugly
so their teachers and preachers
are less tempted
to penetrate them.
No one wants to date someone
with Mount Pimplemanjaro
on their nose.
So just do what I do.
Have your personal makeup artist
shellac your face
with an airbrush.
Voilà.
Blackheads and whiteheads
are identical,
except blackheads
are 20 times more likely
to be choked to death
by the police.
Along with puke, exposed bones,
and Russians,
gross extraction videos are one
of the pillars of this show.
And I'm dying for Dr. Lee
to give my pores a happy ending.
That's why I invited
the Princess of Pus
to join me for this week's
Ce-web-rity Profile.
Hey, what are you in here for?
Augh!
[laughs] Ooh-hoo.
Ugh.
I think the chiropractor's
down the hall.
- I'm not a hunchback.
It's a cyst.
- Huh.
- Daniel, Dr. Pimple Popper
will see you now.
- When did you realize you had
a passion for popping pimples?
- I started to post
popping videos
or blackhead extractions
about a year ago
on my Instagram
and on my YouTube channel,
and they just got
more interest.
So I went and--
I went and looked,
and I saw that there's
a whole community.
There's a subculture
of people...
- There always is.
- Who just post
popping videos
and share them
with each other.
- Although your Instagram
is very confusing
'cause you have, like, normal,
everyday, like,
"Hey, this is me
out and about," sexy photos.
Next thing is the most horrific
extraction I've ever seen.
- The goal is to try to get this
out of a smaller little area.
So if I try to tease
around it...
So a little tightness here,
okay?
How's that? Okay?
- Yeah, it's fine.
- Not bad, right?
[speaking indistinctly]
I think it might be coming.
[groans]
I'm showing that I'm
a real person, you know,
that I may be a physician
and I do all these surgeries
but I'm a girl too.
Like, you know,
all my girlfriends,
I like to hang out with them;
I have a husband.
- And does he work--
- He's a dermatologist.
- Do patients get upset
when they get your husband
and not you?
- Yeah, sometimes.
- [laughs]
What type of person
likes to watch?
- Most of them are women,
I will have to say, I think.
- Women love popping zits.
- Yes, they do.
- I had two older sisters.
As a kid, aw, they couldn't
be happier getting in on me.
- I do know, though,
that a lot of people
like these videos
because they relax them.
They help decrease
their anxiety.
They watch them
during panic attacks.
before they go to sleep, and--
- No, that's not--
none of this is true.
You're making that up.
That is complete horse [bleep].
Nobody watches that video
and then takes a nap.
- All right,
give me some traction.
[speaking indistinctly]
It's, like, ready to come.
It's like I need a suction,
like they do with babies.
- What race of people
has the best skin?
- It's true
that the darker you are,
the less likely you are
to develop wrinkles over time.
Lighter-complected people
are gonna have more
of those fine lines
and wrinkles,
so they look older
probably sooner than Asians,
African-Americans, Hispanics,
all of us darker.
- So you guys win
that one category.
- We do, yeah.
Well, we win in a couple
other ones too.
- Eh...
[laughs]
Do you have to talk
your patients into this?
- No, not usually.
In fact, now people come
from around the world.
I've had people come
from London, from Saudi Arabia
for me to pop their zits.
- Are you making more money
off your videos now
than you are your practice?
- No.
- Are there people
that are watching it
for pleasure, sexual?
- I'm sure there's people
that watch anything,
everything for that.
But I think they're in
the minority.
It's not really a fetish.
It's more--you know, it's like
riding a roller coaster
or watching a scary movie.
I think it makes people happy.
- I don't know.
I think fetish might--
- It doesn't make you happy?
- I think there's more
fetish people in there too.
Combined with the fact
that you're Asian,
that's a double whammy
for a lot of people.
- Maybe.
- I want to know how nasty
these people are.
- They aren't nasty.
They're my patients,
and they're absolutely lovely.
- Filthy monsters.
- No, not at all, no.
- Why is it getting that bad?
- You know,
the biggest blackheads
come from older patients
who have poor eyesight,
who have arthritis
in their hands,
and they just are not aware
that these things
are even on their skin.
The big, like, growths
that we usually see,
especially in the nether areas,
tend to be men.
And I tell them,
"Don't worry about it.
I've seen a lot of skin tags."
And then they pull down
their pants.
And I had one guy with, like,
the size of a racquetball
on his butt,
like, on a piece of his butt.
This has been growing
for how long?
- Oh, a number of years.
- Yeah.
Okay, good.
All gone.
- What'd you do
with that disgusting skin tag
after you cut it off?
- I made it into a key chain.
- Oh, you nasty bitch.
Does anything gross you out?
- Recently I had this woman
who we removed a pilar cyst,
a big benign cyst,
like, about this big,
you know, on her head.
And it was soft.
Like, it was kind of like
a balloon.
But I took it out whole.
But when I cut into it--
afterwards I cut into it
on the table--
it was like black mud
that came out.
- Oh, you nasty bitch!
Talk about the smell.
- You know what it smells like
in general?
It smells like some of those
more strong cheeses.
That's exactly
what it smells like.
- Okay, that's not good.
What's the worst bodily fluid?
- I don't know.
The worst bodily fluid?
Diarrhea.
[both laugh]
- Diarrhea's bad.
What are those [bleep] beans?
When the beans come out
of people, I lose my mind.
- No, you just say,
"Oh, well, look at that."
You know, that kind of thing.
- "You got a magic bean
in you."
And what's the closest
to the butthole
that you've ever had to do
an extraction?
- I don't do the butthole.
- What, do you--
you just let them die?
- I don't do that.
There's, like, pilonidal cysts,
which occur, like,
right above the rectum there.
But I--that's not my domain.
I don't do that.
I'm out.
[both laugh]
- When you see guys naked
all the time...
- Yes.
- Is it uncomfortable for you
at all?
- No, it's not uncomfortable,
but I will tell you
something funny.
That I used to work with--
I worked with a dermatologist
who said that if they were
examining a guy and he got...
- Aroused.
- A hard-on--yeah, aroused...
- You don't say "hard-on."
You're a doctor.
- Oh, sorry.
You're supposed to flick it.
That's what they were doing.
They were flicking it.
I've never had to do that.
- If you flicked my dong...
- I know.
- Oh, I would be so into that.
[both laugh]
Yeah, if you flick a weenie
like that, like,
do one of those,
those pops,
oh, if you tuck it
back behind,
oh, that'll hurt them.
- Oh, okay.
I'll try that out.
- Or make them finish.
This has all been
very informative.
You know, celebrities
have been cashing in
on their terrible skin
for years.
It's time I got in
on the action.
Everyone knows
I have flawless skin,
but sometimes before shows,
I get a small,
barely noticeable stress boil.
I can't wait three days
for my skin
to slightly improve.
I need a more proactive
approach.
That's why Dr. Pimple Popper
is my main squeeze.
[squelching]
The first sign of a blemish,
and I want all hands on zit.
Don't stop squeezing until
there's blood on the mirror.
- Thanks to my sexy
Asian fingers,
the results are instant.
- And the explosive release
feels better
than the best orgasm.
Plus, a little scarring
makes you look like a man.
Got this one from a zit,
this one from a shark.
- Call now,
and she'll throw in
two Bioré bacne strips
for free.
- [screams]
[bleep]!
[sniffs]
By the way, pimple jizz
is made up
of dead white blood cells
and bacteria
and can serve as a healthy
alternative to Miracle Whip
when you're making tuna salad.
We'll be right back, but first,
you know your Steph Curry
crossover is legit
when you break your own skull.